all right welcome everybody we are
standing by for what is sure to be an
absolutely and utterly insane
rally marjorie taylor green under
pressure because
she just seems obsessed with hitler and
calling things like the holocaust
and yet she's out there doing rallies
matt gates
possibly days from being indicted for
things
up to and including child sex
trafficking and he'll be out there
pleading the blood of jesus or call it
what you will
and this is going to be um in about 40
minutes 40 45 minutes
uh or an hour you know who really knows
what these things but coverage scheduled
to start in about 40 minutes
uh i'll be totally upfront front i'm
gonna stay as long as i can i do have
some pending
uh i guess we'd call them service
providers that i will be needing to
attend to
um at my place so i'll stay as long as i
can hopefully we get to some of the
actual rally but we're gonna hear from
people and we're gonna watch clips and a
whole bunch of different things
i'll stay as long as i can and then this
could be an
historic event an historic event
uh but it's gonna be wild so i'm glad
that you are
joining me and i have so many things to
go over with everybody
um people asking for updates
hello updates on the second youtube
channel
now i actually have something very
special to tell people about
the second youtube channel which will
include
clips from these live streams
has already been created we have not yet
started to promote it
because we're just not quite ready yet
but if people want to get subscribed
let's see what what does it actually
look like now let me see here
yeah it's just called pacman live
um yes see here it is look pacman live
and to distinguish it from the main
channel
you can tell it's the other channel
because my hair whoa
because my hair looks wacky in the
thumbnail okay so we'll have a redirect
set up for this very soon
but if you want to be like one of the
first subscribers i guess there's not
much to subscribe to yet but we're gonna
it's gonna launch very soon
um i'm gonna paste the link in the
youtube and twitch chat a little bit
um and people people can get in there
let's see in fact
if we can let's see
can we even pull up oh no hold on
username
live subscriber count there it is 21
people have subscribed i love it
so we're starting from scratch i'm going
back to my grassroots
roots i believe that i can uh
i believe that i can do it again okay
you don't
sometimes you only have one hit it's a
one hit wonder
all right i believe that actually i can
do it again
and we are ready to do it and this is
gonna be a cl
uh a youtube channel that will have
totally different content it's gonna
have lifestyle stuff it might even have
stuff from some upcoming travel i'm
going to be doing it's going to have
um clips from the live stream it's going
to be crazy it's going to be crazy all
right
so um anyway that's enough of that
but we will uh we will see
what what are people did i do something
wrong again are people mad
how are people already mad what did i do
that's wrong
okay anyway boom we have reached our
first 200 subscribers
on the second youtube channel all right
let's get away from that we are standing
by
for matt gates and marjorie taylor green
uh pepe says are you big time enough to
go on howard's
show i i don't think so i don't think so
i don't know why uh it's oh
no oh no
i still have individual email
notification on this youtube channel
turned on i just
got 239 now 271 emails
rest in peace my inbox i've got to turn
that off right away
i don't even know how to do that right
now okay anyway
holy [ __ ] that was a mistake
that was a mistake all right let's um
i just spammed myself if that's not
self-cuckledry i don't know what is
okay so um all right let's get to
let me i just i'm gonna dive in
somewhere i have no
um unban requests to
go over today but i do have
voicemails okay let's do some voicemails
we're gonna do people have been asking
for
quote normal voicemails and of course
normal voicemails are not
all that normal often but let's see
this is just going i'm going to the
people we're getting a sampling of the
town square of the david pakman show
audience
here is the eggman weighing in on the
national anthem
at sporting events okay here we go hi
dave
i think playing the national anthem at
sporting events
absolutely cheapens the national anthem
um
that the bill to keep it the bill to
make uh to take
funding away from teams that don't play
it's absolutely virtue signaling
yeah um it's horrible there's no need
to salute your country before every
sporting event in the whole world by the
way dave even though i know
i love this i completely agree with the
eggman i completely agree
so intellectual liberal you'll never
have children ever
if you did and you went to a school
event every play
concert choir every meeting at any
school
ever has the pledge of allegiance or
national anthem before it
they make parents stand up put your hand
over your heart
it's absolutely disgraceful and
disgusting that you have to have the
salute to your government before that
sounds horrible
that sounds absolutely horrible second
grade [ __ ]
play at school i apologize for the f
word
but if you had enough guts to have
children and perpetuate the liberal
ideology in this world
you would know how horribly
indoctrinated children are
yeah uh maybe i mean would would like a
hipster jewish school do that maybe i'd
have to send my kid to a hipster jewish
school so that they don't have to do the
uh the pledge of the pledge of
allegiance i don't know i don't know but
that's all that's all pretty aggressive
stuff so i i don't i'm gonna
opt out of deciding on that right for
the time being okay
um devon says you're so genuine that i
thought something seriously bad happened
to you when you found out about that
email anyway here's five bucks
thanks devin um okay we have
more of the this is sort of like the
homophobic caller who apparently is also
anti-semitic
let's see what she has to say this is
now i want to be really clear
people have asked just go through the
voicemail
don't pick crazy stuff so far we've seen
the eggman
and now we're getting to uh now we're
now we're getting to this this
woman we've become familiar with i do
want to say thank you to symbolicgamer
for 16 months subscribed via twitch
that's wild
and nasty cues subscribed for 13 months
that is a number one and two very much
appreciate that all right let's take a
listen
i wonder what things would be like
if the role was reversed
where hitler was considered jewish
and he's taking out mostly my people
which are european which is kind of the
truth
what's the concept if hitler was jewish
and wanted to exterminate white people
this is a normal voicemail guys
and is it like a slap in your face for
people
jewish having their own people
take themselves out
oh my god okay
um
there's one more here
well this one's so crazy google voice
seems to not even want to play it
man i don't know what's going on let me
i'll
try once more just to see
here we go i sacrificed so much
for a better version of myself for
somebody who could do things that
i can't oh man it's bumming me out all
right so i'm gonna move on from that
um here's another one and again these
are the ones that don't make it onto the
show because they're three minutes long
and often they don't go anywhere but i'm
just i'm indulging people who say what
is
give us a sense of the totality of
people who call in
good morning i have three things to
discuss
three things first a story
second a definition see it's already
unusable
right you guys understand at this point
my radar is so
honed in where if it takes 30 seconds to
give me the
up the outline of what your voicemail
will be
it's not going to be on the show you
guys understand right
and third question okay the first thing
is the story so we're 15 seconds in
we've established what
the uh sequence of the voicemail will be
three people agreed to burglarize a home
al bill goes inside
while carl acts as a lookout when the
homeowner discovers the burglars
bill shoots and kills him all three
are guilty of felony murder even if
al and carl didn't know bill was armed
right and even though carl was outside
the entire time you guys following
imagine coming in
on monday morning and having 200 of
these to listen to
okay bill is probably also guilty of
old-fashioned first or second degree
murder
right either way a judge will probably
give him the harshest sentence
okay here's the definition what is
felony murder
felony murder is the legal rule that
expands the definition of murder
it is intended to commit the underlying
so anyway i'm not going to keep playing
it but you guys i think
understand alright so that's another
voicemail let's keep going this is
normal voicemails
okay here's another one i'm not
censoring anything
[Music]
hey david this is marcia calling from
michigan
i have a question for you in regards to
the midterm elections as it relates
to people moving out of urban areas
into more suburban and rural now we've
got a meaty
issue now we're talking marsha
rural areas due to working remotely
do you think that this you know trend
towards moving to
less blue quote-unquote blue districts
might lead to some more
blue democrat wins in some suburban or
even rural areas that would be the hope
yeah no that's an in that's actually a
legitimate question which is if you
that's the whole voicemail 37 seconds
guys pithy
to the point perfect audio speaking
clearly
this is how you do a voicemail take take
be like marcia okay
i have hope now that's a really great
question anytime you see a move like for
example
urban to rural of people who would
typically be part of the urban voters
more blue
what effect could that have the answer
is we don't know it's going to be
different in different congressional
districts but
a great question it's an empirical
question it's a demographic question i
love it
beautiful call um here's another we'll
just do like one or two more and i'm not
skipping any
okay so i'm giving you guys the sense
this is the next call this is from the
berkshires
in massachusetts
and by the way i'm warning you guys this
one timed out at three minutes and got
cut off
that's rarely an auspicious sign i'm
just putting that out there
and i'm calling from calling you from
the berkshire mountains in massachusetts
i've been watching a lot of coverage
on the georgia and arizona elections
with their audits and the things they're
doing with that and
the voters the votes my question is
if you could somehow approach this on
your show
is that our democrats going to be
present here
our democrats going to have a hard time
being present here
because it feels as if republicans
are allowed to run these audits all by
themselves without any democratic pro
presence i wouldn't even worry about it
because the audits are bogus
so let me explain i see people in the
chat like not brave soda has no idea
what's going on
um so the question here from sharon is
these audits are
bs but it's only republicans involved so
isn't there some risk to that and the
answer is
if the audits were actually audits and
if they made any difference
then i would say yeah there should be
democrats involved but it's got it's
it's nothing it's garbage it's
completely vapid and so
i i am not uh i'm not worried about it
whatsoever
okay um let's do another one here
um this is risky here is another oh
actually no this one this person is
giving out a lot of
information that shouldn't be on the
show
um
here's someone commenting about all the
anti-semitism that i've been hit with
lately that seems interesting let's
listen
hey david long time viewer and i've seen
how lately you have been sharing
um through various platforms you know
the
the rash of anti-semitic
messages you're getting which i think is
absolutely terrible yeah
um and i just wanted to say if you are
ever
in the market for a six foot five
muscular body guard let me know because
i will totally
beat up somebody for you i think there's
those of us out here who have your back
and we just want to let you know
beautiful phone call absolutely
beautiful phone call okay
so that's a tour through the voicemail
um i see that one two three some
somebody from a 484 as soon as i started
doing this
started dropping bomb after voicemail
bomb on me
and i'm not going to go to them i see
that it's someone who's like desperate
for me to play their their stuff right
now i'm not going to do that
we're done with voicemails for the time
being but i really like
what a lot of those people had to say
okay and
again i'm not condoning violence it's if
it's self-defense guys they're saying if
someone comes after me they would be
there to beat them up
i'm not condoning violence he's talking
about self-defense thank you
i want to say a huge thank you to
adan popoca who just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
better21
just signed up at joinedpakman.com
and cindy talbot just signed up new
members
3 4 and 5 today i also want to say thank
you to some new twitch subscribers and
renewed twitch subscribers
auntie ulika just subscribed for seven
months on twitch
girobo in for two months
the freak at 15 months
6lj also signing up that's putting us at
nine
very much appreciate that and uh we
continue to stand by
for marjorie taylor green and matt gates
and we have a lot of different things
to talk about all right let me go
through my agenda oh and sorry i missed
a bunch of super chats let me see here
um david that's revenge slash karma for
when
the toontoon channel received the new
subscriber email blast it's been a great
channel though thanks for sharing
yeah if you missed it we have launched
our second channel there's absolutely no
content on it
but um if people want to get in early
and then just hold
pacman live is live now what is the
actual
where did the url go i i lost the url
this is crazy
where was that you can any where is the
url does anybody know
oh there it is subscribe to the second
youtube channel there it is thanks
jabygatz
i'm going to paste the link a couple
times i don't even know what we're doing
it's just
the channel launches really really soon
if people want to follow it
um you you you can do that it's going to
be pretty strong totally different
content ryan says i had thought of the
us
i had thought if the u.s subsidized dash
camps for people to use it could force a
lot more transparency around police and
insurance what are your thoughts
yeah the issue of a vehicle-mounted
dashcam civilian
is an interesting one and uh i have one
and um i would be open to hearing if
there's any downsides to it i don't know
if there are
david please wish audrey the happiest of
the birthdays we drank to your health
all night yesterday and it's been a
rough morning we love you you're special
thank you well please don't drink
on my behalf is there going to be a
debate between green and gates to see
who is more depraved there might be
there might be lesson of voicemails
invest in mental health care yikes
do you speak are you learning a third
language my french
is pretty good where i can communicate
uh
i can communicate okay in french um and
when
when my girlfriend and i went to a very
remote
vineyard in the south of france uh the
person giving us the tastings didn't
speak any english
and i just all of a sudden i guess i was
speaking french and i did it so i did
okay
and then my hebrew is like pretty
mediocre
um not nearly as good as my french
david which life hacks have worked for
your garden none
just keep planting stuff until something
doesn't die
that's really it just became a member
through the website i'm super excited to
be able to watch the
world famous bonus show
welcome adan welcome jd
says five bucks says this is when gates
and green finally release the republican
health care plan yeah well said
well said hal doll harry says is there a
similar spike in
anti-yosemite emails
no shockingly there has not been such a
spike
not at all dj glenn says david great
show thanks for the content what are
your thoughts on the recently released
ufo footage
i've done four or five commentaries on
this so far my view on the recently
released ufo uap
footage is that the most likely
explanation the most likely explanation
um is that these are either um things
that look different
than they actually are because of camera
and lens
uh distortions um deliberate or
not or these are foreign
elements of some kind that's my that i
go with occam's razor that's the most
likely thing for me the least likely
thing is these are alien species from
another world
i just don't think that that's the most
uh that's the most likely
i want to say a big thank you to adam
carey
supposedly though the jewish space
lasers are real
and they were deployed by some of those
ufos yeah exactly
adam carey has just signed up at
joinpackman.com
and his new member number 10 today i
appreciate that also thank you to blast
hard chase
for the twitch sub and i guess that's it
number 11. appreciate that
okay let me go next
to hold on what did i have next
oh yeah hold on where was this
you guys want to do the bernie stuff
bernie's bernie's requirements
for hotels the right is going absolutely
crazy
about it we should look at it
it could do it could be an a sort of
personal finance class as well
yeah let's do it okay so here's a still
image from newsmax
everybody's going nuts about the things
that bernie sanders
uh wants now listen a lot of these
things
make a lot of sense to me and i don't
know if these are shared sensibilities
culturally
that bernie and i share as uh as as
neurotic jewish men i don't know but a
lot of this is making a lot of sense so
first one hotel rooms must be away from
elevators and ice machines
i request the same thing is that even
crazy like what's crazy about that
i just made a hotel reservation
yesterday and
there were boxes you could check where
you say
you know different things i asked for
extra pillows so i can prop
myself up when i'm doing my reading i
ask for extra towels because it's a
beach hotel i want extra towels to take
to the beach
and i said away from elevator high
floor away from elevator
right that doesn't seem crazy now
no upgrades i guess this is like a
bernie man of the people thing where
sometimes he's upgraded
and then he'll like trade with a staffer
i don't even know what to make of that
it just it's just like okay maybe
sometimes he gives the staffer
the better room whatever i don't even
care about that all right
room temperature cannot be higher than
60 degrees so
i don't sleep at 60 but i do
set um in the winter i
my nest thermostat for the for the
overnight
i set it at 66. why do i set it at 66.
everything i've read is that sleep for
the average person is better in the mid
60s
and i know that it feels cold if you
walk around at that temperature
so the nest half an hour before my alarm
goes off the nest will bump us
to 70. that seems reasonable
like the word demands to me it's like
these are requests
you know bernie like am i demanding a
certain seat on the airplane or am i
selecting a seat i'm choosing a scene
okay king-sized bed
i give huge preference to a king-sized
bed at a hotel i was just looking at
hotels yesterday
some of the hotels say queen size some
say king
all else being equal i'm going with king
i'm used to a king-sized bed i prefer
the king-sized bed down comforter
i love a down comforter these are
requests this guy's 80.
okay um now it has to be cotton and dark
blue
sounds weird that's weird i'm not gonna
lie about that
that sounds weird rooms must be stocked
with green tea and honey gatorade and
cans of assorted nuts okay i mean i
i think maybe some of the language here
is a little bit
authoritarian when it's probably just
like here's a request list
here's these are requests the framing of
demands to me seems like a little much
but none of this sounds crazy
other than the blanket has to be blue
that's weird
i find that a little weird um
and then so let then let me get to this
other thing because so what's
what's really the issue here okay the
issue here is they constantly try to
frame bernie
as pretending to be a man of the people
and
really he has all of these demands and
all of these particularities and he has
these three houses and he has
you know he's worth 1.1 million dollars
let's talk about the 1.1 million dollars
thing okay come along with me now
on a basic personal finance thing
how does bernie only have 1.1 million
dollars
is my question and i'm gonna talk you
through it okay let's work backwards
starting with
let me make some notes about when bernie
was doing
different things so when did bernie get
elected to the house of representatives
okay
1991 to 2007
so for 16 years bernie was in the house
of representatives
let's just look at the salary house of
representatives
salary uh history
okay here we go so 1991
it was um
hold on it says only senators what does
that mean
only senators only representatives
1991. okay so bernie was making 125k
in 91 and then in 92
it was 130 and then 93
it was 133 so okay
since 1991 through now
bernie has been making six figures let's
just
assume bernie is able to save you know
some some reasonable amount of money um
i don't know like let's say bernie saves
15 of his gross salary or something like
that
so he's saving you know two three
thousand dollars
four five let's let's just do a simple
future value of money calculator
okay 1991 to now is 30 years
let's say at that time bernie had i
don't know
like 50 grand saved up we're gonna use
just a six percent
rate of of savings and let's imagine
that
every year bernie sanders was able to
add i mean the thing is like
in the early 90s 15 would be like three
grand but then that would be more
like six let's just say on average
bernie saves five grand a year
okay uh that alone
is six hundred and eighty two thousand
dollars by today
okay and thirty years ago bernie was
already 50 years old
there's no way bernie had only 50 grand
when he was 50 years old
if you tweak these just slightly let's
say bernie had a nest egg
again he he's a 50 year old at the time
let's say he had a nest egg of
a hundred thousand dollars and he was
able to save
seventy five hundred dollars per year
that's
1.1 million and we're not even talking
about
his house where and he got a then there
was a
you know somebody died and he inherit so
when all of these republicans say look
at
bernie the socialist with 1.1 million
dollars which was his disclosed net
worth a couple of years ago
my question is with what bernie's been
earning
and with bernie's age and with the
effect of compounding interest
how does bernie only have a net worth of
1.1 million dollars at what was then age
76 or something like that anyway
it's crazy guys it's it's really really
crazy
uh he should have i'm surprised that
that's all
the money that bernie has based on his
salary for the last 30 years
okay let's move on i think i've made my
point
um so we're done with the future value
of money calculator we're done with
bernie
we're done with salaries
okay um
[Music]
i guess that we're good there very good
okay let me get back to some of these
super chats
john says i've traveled for business to
over 100 countries
about 70 of my time do not blame bernie
for asking
for these simple easily satisfied
requests love it
hal doll harry says the elderly usually
like high temperature good for bernie i
don't know that to be true i don't know
feisty fans as bernie's demands are like
basic he's more basic than me
jay howard says congratulations on your
show david i think you're in there
keep going thank you
matt says did you reschedule your
appearance on matt dillahunty's show i
have not actually i should do that i've
just been so busy
i have very little extra time and
desiree says you're so funny david i
love your dry humor and how it lightens
the otherwise bad news of the day thank
you i appreciate that desiree
i appreciate it very much ethan says
hola mi hermano it's oz
great to see you oz also want to say
thank you to crimson elric
for subscribing now for 18 months via
twitch
and says hey david when is the fcc going
to start pulling the broadcast licenses
of these opinion networks fox oan
and newsmax what are your thoughts i
don't think anytime soon
i don't think it's going to happen
anytime soon um
oh and i do have to keep an eye just so
everybody knows i'm gonna stay for as
much as i can of the rally
i have a hard out when some service
providers arrive
and then i'm gonna have to go deal with
that so i'm gonna try to stick around
but we we may end up having to watch
some of this separately which i know
would be tragic for me
for sure sinsu says
i wish these clowns weren't so
entertaining i hate it but i can't look
away i know
i know and ryan says what are your
thoughts on republicans most likely
blocking the january 6th commission
yeah not surprising but i mean listen
they're going to end up implicated in it
so of course they're blocking it
of course they're blocking it um
yeah i'm not even gonna fall i know that
people say david the coupon code's not
working so that i will pull it up and
prove that it's working
every coupon code is working fine people
are using it better 21 works immoral 21
works all of the coupon codes work
okay very good let me go to my next
element here
here is joe biden after or right before
getting ice cream i've not pre-screened
this but i'm told that it's a it's a
funny clip of some
kind somehow it's funny uh let's take a
look at it together
i can't imagine anyone voting against
establishing the commission
on the greatest assault since the civil
war on the council
but at any rate
[Music]
i love it i love the ice cream you real
ice cream really bridges the gap
between um between what
by the way i just had one of the best
ice creams this is not an endorsement
let me see if i can actually find it
um
oh what this was this was like a perfect
flavor
oh is this the brand
nope this wasn't it hold on
oh this is it right here this is
i have never had an ice cream like this
okay get ready for a recommendation
this is a huge endorsement i'm making
breaking
this is the brand right here i've i
randomly found this
graters black cherry chocolate chip
i've never experienced anything like
this
this is a perfect ice cream
perfect ice cream the cherry pieces
combined with the chocolate pieces i
know i'm going to anger some people i
don't know the politics of these people
we know ben and jerry's the politics we
know about it
um this is better than cherry garcia
it's it's not even close and i think
that there are people who are going to
be furious with me
over that statement this is a far better
cherry ice cream than cherry garcia
um it's more perfect than that ukrainian
phone call
not sponsored this is not an advertiser
guys
beautiful ice cream and for people who
care
no gluten in it no fish no peanuts
no shellfish no tree nuts and no
wheat none of it um
oh and sweetened with cane sugar you
like to see that
you like to see that beet juice for
color
just brilliant absolutely brilliant ice
cream
okay so i ran i've learned about that
ice cream the other day and it really
cannot be beat
clip that guys that needs to go on the
new channel my ice cream review okay
um if you're just joining us by the way
you can now subscribe to the new channel
there's nothing there the new channel
launches soon
but i'm doing what's called
pre-promotion this is pre-promotion
and if people want to sign up i posted
the um
i posted the link before in twitch and
youtube
and we were at zero at the start of the
stream we're building a new channel i'm
doing it again guys
we're starting over at zero and we're
going to do it again so
really exciting really really exciting i
want to say thank you also to brian
murphy brian just signed up at
joinpackman.com
really appreciate that brian thank you
also tool fan just signed up via twitch
thank you for that as well um
oh there's the link okay yeah sorry i'll
paste the link
i keep losing the link in my clipboard
but uh there it is if people want to
pre-sign up for the channel there's
really no advantage other than
what is what what are we even doing i
don't know you'll know when we publish
something
so that's that a believer of
anti-pedophile conspiracy theory
is on tour with an alleged child
trafficker what is normal i know
yeah these america first events are just
bizarre
there's there should be legislation
passed on rent caps not against that
yeah
david have you seen the zero coveted
grifters on twitter who come up with a
new variant story every week other
experts saying it's an insane grift yeah
yeah yeah
was your douglas murray interview your
most bizarre oh not even close
well that question triggered me so much
i just spilled my water
no in fact if you guys want to look whoa
we might get our first
thousand subs on the new channel right
now
that's crazy it's going to be
clips from the live streams gardening
uh lifestyle elements
you know all sorts of different things
do you guys
want to see what was really one of the
most bizarre interviews ever as we stand
by we actually have a few minutes here
let's just dive into it i think a lot of
people may not know about this
this was when i interviewed pastor james
david manning who claimed that
starbucks was making people addicted
to their frappa whatever by putting
not just semen in them the semen of gay
men specifically
that's not a joke okay let's review i'm
joined today by pastor james david
manning who's the chief pastor at atla
world missionary church
in harlem here in new york city just a
few miles north of our studio
pastor manning has been a strong critic
i think is even an understatement
if you want to see a bizarre interview
just watch this
okay of president obama comparing
president obama to
satan hitler calling him a long-legged
mack daddy
pastor manning is your objection to
president obama primarily to him as a
person or to his political views
him as a person uh but surely
because of his personhood his political
views
are demented uh evil
as well but that stems from him as
a person so we'll let it rest there are
you a political
conservative in other words do you when
you say you disagree with president
obama on his view this gets really nuts
this is the one of the most insane
interviews i've done
is that because you're you're a
conservative no
i'm a christian i i wholeheartedly
support
the word of god the bible and so i
wouldn't necessarily call myself a
conservative in that regard
a christian point of view covers both
the political
and also the theological perspective
when you refer to president obama
as a long-legged mack daddy this is
something which has been turned into
sort of a joke amongst many but i've
never actually heard you explain
what what that means what what exactly
did you mean by that
yeah it is both a spiritual and a social
designation that is spot-on
for who he is as a person personality
the term long-legged mack daddy derives
from the
street hood term of being a
daddy young boys the uh etymology is uh
actually greek but it was adopted early
during the french renaissance
years ago uh in their sexual encounter
with young girls within the hood
uh and the moment of the sexual
experience would ask the young lady
who's your daddy
uh in and out of bed that question was
raised uh and it made the man sing
macho and the woman very submissive
the term mac has is a term that has
supplanted
the term the old term the iceberg slim
term of a pimp which has a very negative
connotation to it
so it's been supplanted by the word mack
so when men who earned
their living from putting women out on
the street
this should be remixed if officer
akeemov is watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here
or otherwise uh taking money from women
for sexual favors
uh were then considered mac well a mac
daddy is a person who professionally
does that does nothing else
but that with women and a long-legged
mcdaddy is the most successful pimp
on planet earth and which women which
women has president obama put out on the
street
well you know the the ones that voted
for him the one that gave
loads and loads of money and told
tons and tons of lies and ran extreme
interference on behalf of him and all
those old white women sitting up in the
stadium's
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong
uh during the 2008 campaign watching him
speak and swooning
over him nothing more than the biggest
pimp job i've ever seen
but can you name any of the ones that
are now out on the street as you say
well you know the the pimp game as the
term
pimp uh has been usurped by the term
mack the pimp game doesn't who knew
pastors knew so much about pimping
streets anymore it's a very
sophisticated org and a sophisticated
uh kind of an organization oh officer
officer akimov is here
uh that's beautiful now where you call
girls you simply call up or you can go
to
uh the gramercy list or somebody's list
and or you can go online it's still
pimping
i see so obama did it where it's like a
high class
pimping of sorts he's not literally i
see
let's call it that okay uh you talked
about this christian world view that you
have and for people who don't know your
background you did uh you've admitted to
to breaking into as many as 100 houses
you have threatened people with guns you
spent about three and a half years
in prison and in prison is where you
developed you became a christian so to
speak
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
first of all i didn't threaten people
with guns i put a double barrel shotgun
sort of shotgun
in the mouth of a low-life small time
if you will mafiosa type nice guy right
yes the name
jasper zizzo i put it in his mouth and
threatened to blow his brains out that's
the only person on this are you guys
noticing that there's
constant um sort of sort of like uh
um what's the word i'm looking for sort
of like
there's constant gay innuendo in
everything this guy says
this planet i've ever threatened with
the gun so we need to be straight about
that
i don't know if i don't know if i broke
into a hundred houses i know over a
period of about three or four years i
went into a large number of them and
stole things that i had no business
stealing
and i regret to this very day did i live
that life uh there's not a day that goes
by that i do not regret that however
one of the things that happened to me
while in prison i turned around and
looked at myself and said what on earth
am i doing here how did i get here
why did i turn out to be the kind of
person that i turned out to be that
would end up in prison this is not
my father's son so i got down on my
knees
and i simply you guys you're hearing all
of it right like if you this is
am i imagining this i wanted uh to be
and i didn't fully understand but i
wanted the burden of how i had treated
my family how it embarrassed my school
teachers and my parents
i wanted that burden lifted from me and
i the only person i knew
could do it was jesus he not only lifted
that burden from me but he saved me
and it's changed my life dramatically
and how how did you know
to go to jesus and let me kind of
contextualize that question
you go into prison and you recognize
that you're
you're on the wrong path like you said
you're not your father's son
did you test out like did you check with
allah did you check
with with a you know the god of abraham
and then jesus and then the
the god of the flying spaghetti monster
how did you ultimately
settle on jesus right i'm glad you
raised that question because
in prisons and during the 70s when i was
there
the islamic floor influence is still
very powerful
most men convert to islam because it
gives them a sense of
being protection etc and so i did
i did bow down to allah twice in my cell
on two consecutive nights thinking that
that would be
bring what i needed nothing happened
when i prayed to allah
but the very first night i prayed to
jesus who
was my grandmother's god and the god of
my father and my uncles and aunts
for many many moons when i prayed to him
instantly
the power of god met me and i was
changed there's no doubt about it
otherwise i wouldn't be talking
he felt it deep in his loins he means
you today had not been dramatically
changed
by the power of the blood of the lord
jesus christ and it's interesting
because
in your political views you've been very
strongly
uh condemning homosexuality for for many
years you've talked about uh
gay people being stoned to death you've
talked about sodomite slayers
uh you've talked about gay semen and
starbucks coffee but i want to put that
conversation off a little bit yeah we
that's a conversation we're going to
need to really
you know segment out so let's not jump
into the gay semen yeah
are you what's your reaction to the
reality that
you want to see gays stoned to death and
isis
wants to stone gaze or they've even
thrown gays off of the roofs of
buildings
are you comfortable sharing a view so
precisely with an extremist muslim group
right well i gotta tell you that if
my view does not come from isis or any
other jihadist for that matter no no
no let me let me clarify the question i
didn't suggest your views
came from that but what i'm saying is
they happen to be identical
well yeah that's what i'm trying to say
to you i'm trying to tell you that my
views come from the word of god from the
book of leviticus
from the writings and teachings of moses
that says
that every sodomite needs to be stoned
to death not just sodomites but
adulterers
as well my point of view comes from
so now if it happens to be synonymous
with isis or some other point you can't
help that
not my problem right my problem is to
reverence the word of god
to trust it to preach it to teach it
and if the word says stoned then that's
what it says
that is no but but so but so you admit
that the the christian doctrine you
claim your views are informed by
has led you to the exact same place that
the the followers of isis have been led
to
by supposedly following muslim doctrine
you recognize that wholeheartedly
no i think what you're tr what you're
failing to understand is you're trying
to make what
the muslims do worse than what
moses has said do in fact
any christian any true christian or
follower of the word of god
were probably more extreme than isis
or in some of the other jihadists when
you look at the teachings of the lord
jesus christ
and the things that he has said and this
and that's sanctioned
because jesus said let me just make sure
we're not missing any of that
and for joining us okay a little run
that's going to start soon so we'll
we'll get back to that whatever
laws that moses have put forward
including and we'll even skip ahead a
little bit here actually no we don't
have to
we're speaking with pastor james david
manning we're going to take a break on
our tv and radio program and we'll
continue speaking with pastor manning
including his claims about sodomite
semen and starbucks coffee the full
interview
will be available on our youtube channel
so let's go to that next pastor yeah
you've talked about starbucks uses gay
semen
in their coffee to make it taste good
where did that come from
well i i think you know that there was
an article
that was first promoted suggesting this
idea
and was then later i remember from when
i did this interview that at one point
he says
isn't the term flat white obvious what
they're talking about
i i i'm like anxiously waiting for us to
get to that moment in the interview
retracted as just a hoax let me say
something to you about
marketing and about major corporations
no but
let me pause because we have limited
time with you and we talk a lot about
marketing and corporations
i just want to know why you think that
it would be specifically
because of the coffee because it's true
because
gays tend to love other each other's
semen
and it flavors up the coffee they like
the taste of it it flavors it
up what does that mean it flavors it up
there's no doubt about that how do you
know that it flavors the coffee
well because that's what it does like
the cocaine that was put in coca-cola
going back a century ago
this is this is nuts right this is crazy
flavored up coca-cola and they now
introduced
have introduced a synthetic cocaine that
gives coca-cola the same kind of
flavor and excitement and addiction of
taste well starbucks
has done the exact same thing that
coca-cola has done
except they've done it with semen but
enlighten me on the logistics so if i go
into a starbucks and i say
i want a you know medium vanilla latte
bs whatever thing i want right and i see
them take the different ingredients the
milk and then the coffee and whatever
at what point are they collecting the
semen where when are they inserting it
in my drink
right oh it's already in the process
it's already in the pipeline but it's a
process guys it's a pipeline you know
it's just it's a pipeline it's a process
it's it's
it's in you can't it's just it can't be
removed by the way
starbucks has already have just
introduced a flat
white uh drink latte
or mocha i'm not sure which it's a latte
that's a cover for semen right
it is eerily uh as if they're almost
mocking me like they're saying the flat
white guys that was the drink
that's the drink we'll show you that
we're doing it
and the stupid starbucks audience of a
patronage
doesn't have enough sense to believe you
manning we'll actually put it
we'll hide it in plain sight what
condition does this guy have
right i mean this is crazy
this is this is just out of this world i
mean this is absolutely incredible what
starbucks is doing
because they recognize their audience
and their patron is uh
just a bunch of idiots who will drink it
no matter what's in it they're drinking
it with cyanide in it well listen the
the gay semen and coffee aside i think
that there's no question
that that the issue of homosexuality is
a really important one to you
and i think that you you admitted in an
interview
with uh jenk and anna over at the young
turks that at one point
you yourself were tempted by what you
call the gay lifestyle what
tell us about that i don't know about
the gay lifestyle that's an addition
i was in prison in my early 20s and yes
i was tempted
to engage in a sexual intercourse with
a uh of the sodomite no doubt about it
yeah i did that's an
intercourse i didn't do it and thank god
that jenk and anna
had the integrity to publish the fact
that i said i was tempted but i didn't
yield to temptation right
i thought about at one point in time
while i was in prison of committing
suicide i didn't do that either
but i was tempted but what so what were
your temptations
uh brought on by in other words you were
you're in prison
you considered yourself i assume a
heterosexual male
right what happened that made you say
maybe i'll have the gay
gay intercourse been a long time without
a woman that's what it was
it was a long time without a woman and
uh you know just watching it go on and
and seeing other people do it and i
thought to myself well
you know maybe i will yeah you know i
didn't but i thought about it it had
been a long stretch without a woman but
in the situation you were in it struck
you as an idea that might have been
pleasurable
yeah i did no i thought i don't know if
it's something that i would be proud of
in that regard pleasurable but in terms
of
sensations of the flesh no doubt about
it that was the only reason i would
consider that sensation of the flesh
but i would not have been proud of it i
can tell you that
pastor manning i've spoken over the
years to many uh individuals who condem
homosexuality to varying degrees here we
go right
he's you know similar to the way you do
including uh for example dr paul cameron
and many of them have admitted to having
had i guess what we could call
colloquially gay temptations
what do you think of the fact that there
are so many
outspoken anti-gay activists who end up
being gay steve wiles george reekers and
ted haggard and pastor eddie long
i don't know if that's someone that you
saw in the kind of pastoring world
troy king and glenn murphy jr why do you
think that there's this path that has
existed in
several dozen of these individuals who
are publicly
very it's a good question i have to say
anti-gay activists
and then it turns out they themselves
are gay well you know
not every person who's anti-gay has been
gay or
is gay themselves of course i i think we
need to understand be clear about that
but the other thing i think there's an
old adage in the preaching industry if
you will
that one of the hardest preachers is
someone
who was either a former drug addict or a
former criminal or one who really was at
the pit of hell
all right yeah so then he equates being
gay with a drug addiction so
anyway that's pastor david manning we're
standing by at an america first rally
with
uh congress people gates and green uh
yes
matt gates and marjorie taylor green i'm
gonna stick around as long as i can and
i'm gonna keep an eye on my phone which
which i know is rude but
i'm waiting for some service providers
to get here at which point i will have
to abandon the stream
uh but hopefully we can we can see some
of it um to some degree
uh welcome to everybody coming over from
the nicole sandler show
appreciate the raid also big thank you
to uh oh i guess no one listen
if you have amazon prime and you've not
given your twitch prime sub to anybody
i will take it now that we're close to
the end of the month just make sure
you're using it because otherwise bezos
keeps the money
if you don't use the twitch prime sub
jeff bezos keeps
the money
you understand right okay we don't want
that we certainly don't want that
all right other um super chats coming in
it's so sad this guy has a platform and
that people will believe his craziness
yeah absolutely
this whole time i thought it was steamed
milk in my coffee yeah
danny says to tie this into yesterday's
old interview with that north dakota guy
this harlem pastor probably got a okay
yeah
we can't do that danny that's edgy
that's edgy we can't do that
um takes a pimp to noah pimp sounds like
a bootleg
louis armstrong remix this
to the song return of the mac oh that's
an interesting idea
for mack daddy pacman why does this guy
sound like bobcat goldthwait
that's a fair question that's actually a
really really good question
all right let's listen to the right side
broadcasting coverage of what is sure to
be
a completely unhinged event here let's
take a listen you never know when big
tech is going to censor us again
just those five seconds are nuts as well
as some of our newer accounts like
telegram
telegram is a great platform that we
have never telegram from i think it's
safe to say that's the only one
that we've never had to deal with
censorship on so it's right side
broadcasting network you'll see that
we're verified there as well
we post a lot of events there as well so
in case anything
god forbid ever happens god forbid big
tech might censor them and it would be
divine action
i'm going to step off the microphone or
i'll be on the microphone i'm going to
step off the side
to the camera so we can pan these crowds
yeah and show you guys the room
we are 19 minutes out of marjory taylor
green and matt gates's speech here
tonight at the america first and the
term speech is a very loose term here
looks like a high school gym
[Music]
okay so we
are uh standing by they cut the audio
not me
but we are standing by
um it's all very weird i don't know that
there's anybody under 60 here no chat on
youtube if you guys want to get your
donations rolling or if you have any
shout outs it doesn't even have to be a
donation
let me know you can tag me liz willis
and it'll highlight my name so i can see
that pretty easily we have 1.1
000 watching right now so thank you to
everyone tuning in
there's more people watching this stream
of their stream than they're actually
watching their stream that's wild
um okay very good so we're standing by
for that
and i also want to say thank you to
chantal
nadeau chantal nado has just signed up
at joinpackman.com
and his new member number 15.
very much appreciate that and uh thanks
to william hayes
as well as zog heed tom
mental entropy wait that's one two three
four
j me and j x kareem are five and six
bungles bob and lurker are seven and
eight
drachter and hakka are nine and ten
subscribing today via twitch
that we very very much appreciate max
headroom called wants his image back
matt gates
wow they got 30 geriatrics to show up
this spring is brings up january 6th
vibes
i'm actually concerned i don't think
there will be an insurrection at this
event
i really don't uh i don't i don't think
so i don't think we have much to worry
about there
uh thank you also to libster tech and
lebron gaming for signing up via
a twitch prime i appreciate that and um
we will am i willing to create a new
coupon code i mean i guess
is there a particular coupon code people
want sometimes people find it
let's make a new coupon code what do
people want
uh triggered no more maybe buy buy covid
what's a coupon code that would be
compelling
insurrection no we're not gonna do that
that's that's that's a little weird
they can't be they can't it can't be
that uh coupons let's see
pack for flat white yeah there's an idea
i think we're going to stay away from
flat white
something about the new channel people
are actually liking flat white that's
funny
bernie 60 degrees rainbow creamer that's
not
bad uh
pack daddy no i don't think so guys
that's weird
trump indictment
blue blanket none of these are striking
me as
obvious
edible glitter that's strange
what about yeah i like the idea of
something with sir what about
discount sir would that work
discount sir
i would do that discount sir
felony 21 that's the winner that's the
winner okay
the coupon code that's just instantly
the right one oh
nicely done the new coupon code i'm
making it right one
right now felony 21 i'm gonna make it a
healthy discount
uh because it strikes me as almost
illegal
um let me make sure this is all working
correctly publish
all right the new coupon code on the
website is felony21.
it's so extreme that you would imagine
that it is illegal um and let me
flush the cash there it is felony 21.
um in second place is hair dye 21. i
like that as well but the coupon code
at joinedpakman.com is felony 21 it
should be a felony to accept such a huge
discount code love it
absolutely love it okay other super
chats coming in as we stand by flat
white is how you describe gates face
dave take calls the old way i can't use
discord sorry the old way is gone
we don't have the old way anymore we
just don't
what's unique about the us of a one side
of the two-party system is represented
publicly by an investigated child sex
trafficker
unironically someone needs to get matt
gates away from any high school
that is a good point how is matt gates
even allowed to do events at high
schools given what he's being
investigated for
that is an absolutely perfect question
um let's listen and take in the ambiance
here
they're able instead of being a big name
they're using their power to support
other patriotic companies which is
exactly what we want to be doing
patriot mobile can you imagine but we
speak with our wallets and our voices
so we are excited to talk to you guys a
little bit more about them
real she has a lot of stage presence
that's for sure thanks to weather boxer
as well as cosmic harry trout
for signing up via twitch that's 30.
also a huge thank you to megan solo
for gifting five subs on twitch thanks
megan
and lastly colin fawn new user
and tj mackey have also grabbed
twitch prime subscriptions from the
standpoint of the website
raylene joseph has just signed up
and joseph phillips the first ever to
use the coupon code
felony21 be really careful with that
coupon code
felony21 uh the first person ever to use
it is joseph
phillips as we stand by for marjorie
taylor green and matthew gates
please leave your cane and dentures at
the door says barefoot runner
i don't want to be ageist i mean like
i'm aware that the demographics here are
the this is an uh an older crowd
but we don't want to be ageist we have
anti-vaxxers in the rally and this will
be a super spreader event
um it may be jessica says i performed at
a bigger stage
in my eighth grade musical which also
had more people
and better lighting and that was the
early 1980s
well said jessica well said thanks to
robert slavins who just signed up with
the coupon code felony21
also thank you to colby zavala who just
signed up using that
exact same coupon code
john says currently trying to extract
gates from the girls locker room yeah to
me it seems
irresponsible honestly to do a matt
gates event at a high school
that just seems alec asking for trouble
um thanks to anonymous gifter mike ox
oh my god we're getting away from that
almost got me there
michael uh michael has signed up
anonymous gifter
random drama prfc kian soros
signing up that is five more via twitch
also thank you to heather sanders for
signing up on my website with the code
felony21
and carl goodrich has signed up with the
code felony21
appreciate that we are moments moments
moments away
from matt gates and marjorie taylor
greene
[Music]
and why we care i don't know
bay photo says let's play a game guess
the vaccinated percentage of the crowd
i would say
30 percent 30 percent maybe
a large indoor gathering of an
unvaccinated overweight
sedentary elderly folks what could go
wrong that's uh
that's that's that's your thing that's
your thing thanks to taco weasel for the
twitch sub
silly facetious dragon has also gifted
five
49 plus six five six hero i'm going to
55.
appreciate that a lot of handshaking
happening in the crowd as you can see
um not a mask in sight guys listen the
cdc guidelines are if you're vaccinated
you don't have to wear a mask indoors so
i'm sure all these people are vaccinated
rick says keep up the great work grand
bellow says is it possible the audits
are a big voter data mining scheme maybe
for fundraising
certainly anything is possible anything
is possible with these
people john gregson just signed up with
the code
felony21 carl stratton just signed up
anthony gribinus just availed
himself of the coupon code felony21
putting us at 58.
this isn't brian fisher right here is it
just just a dead ringer for him
the crowd is just left over from the
timeshare seminar
wow you guys are brutal brutal brutal
brutal
let's listen to what's being here's a
young guy right here
looking forward to it all
oh i guess they cut the audio feed
there is a bake sale out front i'm sure
thanks to larry mckenzie cattycatia
pv on um
for the twitch subs putting us at 61.
just a reminder
broadcasting network we're going to
continue to pan these crowds as it fills
in
we are nine minutes shy of the event
starting here today in georgia
we've got a right side broadcasting just
as a reminder i'm going to stay as long
as i can but i do have to run
when i get a message that a uh
a service provider will be arriving
doing some work here
so i will stay as long as i can and
hopefully we get to see some of this
rally together
just join the stream have you talked
about bobert's new pronouns yet
no lauren bobert pronouns let's see
what's up with that
lauren bobert mocked for declaring my
pronoun is patriot which is not a
pronoun right
oh that's that's brilliant that is
brilliant let me see if i can find that
um lauren beaubert
whoa hold on lauren beaubert
pronoun let's see if there's video of
that
uh it might not be on video
no lauren patriot
no that's that's really funny though um
her new pronoun is patriot that's genius
it's almost evil genius it's uh
yeah love your show david on that beer
emote what's in your glass
do you drink tree house or trillium no
in the beer emote i think it's
allagash white or white as some say
how many of these folks would publicly
say they are vaccinated just to not mask
up
many i'm sure many i'm sure
historically accurate quotes wants me to
shout out
your math professor he is professor ian
artemy
from alden university he is famous for
discovering
alden's number big fan oh wow what is
that alden's number
alden's number
a rhetorical strategy used to call out
someone who is pretending to be
knowledgeable about a topic they know
nothing about
have you ever heard of alden's number i
believe so
i literally just made that up you're so
full of [ __ ] i like that see
you didn't trick me i think that was an
attempt to trick me
into pretending to know about alden's
number
i have no problem saying i've never
heard of that so i think i passed the
test right
did i pass the test
i passed it very good very good
i do want to say thank you to anthony
durr for signing up with coupon code
felony oh god my my pillow hold on to be
down in west palm beach this weekend
there's a big boat parade happening for
those who don't know
it's boaters for trump they're putting
it on and it's going to be west palm
beach memorial day
will you be there i will we actually
leave so after this rally tonight we
actually leave at five in the morning
and we're driving
i refuse to fly because i will not put
on a
i don't want to get you guys in trouble
but you watch so much i love it i don't
even have to brief you rsv
and we are not i feel you so you're
gonna drive are you driving straight to
west palm beach
they're driving straight there
absolutely okay let me get back to those
thank yous
anthony durr just signed up with coupon
code felony 21 careful
careful jacqueline deangelis just signed
up with coupon code felony21
marcus zara just signed up
dan fawcett is a new member and jawa
oda just signed up also using that
felonious coupon code felony21
also thanks to omadar for the twitch sub
i appreciate that
um how dare tinder not allow me to
declare patriot as my gender preference
i know it's discriminatory right
how dare they i think all the boats are
really full because a lot of people are
going
and a lot of people are flying in so
they don't have boats i know there was
like some charter buses available but
those are all full i mean boats
available those are all full so
sounds like a real party huh no if
you're in the boat you only see what's
behind you and in front of you
if you're on the shore you see all the
boats so
under the bridge is my advice there's
like a
there's i think there's two bridges and
all the vote boaters for trump like
why what's the point at this by this
point at this stage of the game
have some rsp and crew there as well to
be interviewing people
so you might have you'll probably have a
better view than i do honestly
if y'all saw the boat parade in tampa
florida
i was getting rocked i was soaking wet
by the end of it
the waves did not
help for a broadcast so it'll be fun
but again you guys that's my friend
ashley the unsilent patriot you can find
her on instagram
yeah there you go um with all these
strong boaters how did biden even win
that's a that's that's what shocked
trump yeah
imagine making an infomercial pillow
such a big part of your personal
identity
i know it's it is something else it is
something else
if you're just joining us we do have
sort of like a jokey new coupon code
it's felony 21. it's so cheap it's
almost a felony
and a whole bunch of people have used it
at jointpakman.com we're standing by for
matt gates and marjorie taylor green
i'm gonna stay as long as i can but i do
have uh
i i do have to go when the time to go
comes because i've got some work being
done here
so i will uh i will stay until i can no
longer stay
lara trump now has a show he sold out
event there are no seats left right now
at standing room
sold out isn't it free peace seating has
even filled up so another
successful event yeah it looks like it's
it looks like it's it's free isn't it
if you'd like to donate please consider
donating via the youtube super chat i'm
happy to read those donations
out loud and i want to encourage you
guys and remind you please
like and share this stream it's so
important to us it's completely free to
you
don't underestimate the power that you
have with your social media platforms
yeah all right so there it is and
unfortunately guys i have just received
a message that
my uh my service provider is here so
i've gotta run
um you can watch this on right side
broadcasting i'm glad to have had the
opportunity to share some of this time
with you guys
and um if if this wraps relatively
quickly i'll come back i wish i wish the
timing were different but it is what it
is
all right so gates and green gates and
green
uh someone promote the coupon code yeah
it's felony 21 is the coupon code all
right guys
um see you soon hopefully tomorrow if
not
in a half hour if i can get back they
may be running late which would be great
for us actually see you soon